Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier.
And welcome back to Little Nightmares.
Now we got screwed over just a little bit by who I now know is "The Janitor."
And I'm just guessing that the Janitor's job is to clean up the mess left behind by err'one else.
Ah- NO!
Not this time.
No no no no no no no no....
You with your cra-  No that is not me
Stop grabbing the pipe like that
Ah-hey OHHHH okay well
Ain't this a conundr-
No!  Nononono
Maybe if I am real sneaky peeky like this.
Once you grab that pipe,
I'm gonna go for it.
Oh ye- oh ooh ooh ooh.
Yeah that pipe th-that pipe ain't me!  That ain't me buddy boo, that ain't me.
No no no, don't even try it.
Alright Raticus, you're going to have to take the bait for me on this one and jus-
You know just take one for the team here!
'Cuz I like to think that we are all cooperating in the attempt to not die.
Are those filled... (takes a deep breath) are those bags filled with children?
And also why-aw no aw no- I'm, I'm-  AHHH!
OKAY!  I-- I thought, you know...
I thought there was a possibility you weren't gonna do that.
I thought that I would have a chance to NOT be instantaneously killed.   So I'm gonna GO...
(panicked noises)
Oh no...... Oh no oh no oh no! (more panicked noises)
Okay, alright then.  Hoobade boop.  Hoobade boop.
Oh, wow, wow, you got some reach on you- Holy shit. holy shit, you got some reach on you
Okay, so what I got to do... No no no no no nooo no no you dont!
Okay.  I climb up here, I dont know what Im supposed to be doing.
Oh that thing is still crushing
Frick a frack a lack.
Okay, there's got to be a way...
Oh- oh oh oh oh whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa.
Okay so there's got to be a way...
Maybe I could...  Oh no does it want me to.... oh no.
That might be the thing... maybe it wants me to try to.... to, like, you know.
I-i-it ugh this might be a little grody but... eeeEEEE
OHHH!
Oh.. AHH! no I thought I could grab a little more, but you grabbed ME instead!
So this is like a boss fight- Oh, I see
so I've gotta... whoa oh
not today, not today
not today not today not today
where ya going, where ya going with your hands there? ookay
ehh whoa nooooo! ugh frick ah god damn it
he didn't have me but I thought he had me and then he didnt have me
so I know its like a boss fight
probably a rule of threesome going on here
oh yeah oh yeah yeah don't don't even bother trying to grab that oh WHOA
AH fucking god dammit
ah man this is brutal, its brutal!
but i'm going get you
okay I got one I got one I got one
i'm going for a twofer
i'm going a real twofer here
so I got to make sure that Topher Grace over there
doesn't grab onto what he doesn't need to grab onto-
bam- OH!
(muffled, in-game scream, mixed with ominous music)
(multiple sounds of disbelief/disgust)
so gross
aw jesus
aww man the one thing that guy had going for him was his arms
and now he's just got his stubby legs and nothing to show for it
so ha! I stopped right before the boss battle didn't I?
should have gone
just a little bit farther last time but ya live and ya learn
Ohhh I got an achievement- I unlocked it
I- I finished "The Lair"
I was THAT CLOSE?! Sorry guys
Ahh but carrying on-
That was- Oh! I'm asleep? Okay..
Whatever you say buddy-boo, whatever you say
God- that poor guy- I mean, 1 he was going to die obviously because
Probably the INCREDIBLE blood loss is gonna get to him eventually but,
boy
Howdy thats,
Thats a
Thats a bad way to go after a little, little tiny creature and then ya end up with that happening to ya-
IMA GO FOR A RIDEEE Awww I thought I was going to grab on to the HOOook
Can I go out here?
Is there something out here?
I'm-- woahhh,,
frick-a-dick okay??
Do I wanna do- OOOWOAOohh god oH GOD OH GOD OH GOD
IM GONNA GRAB ONTO THAT I THINK
Err kay I didn't do that apperently
Did I-- Gra- I don't- gr where am I?
gr- where am I??
can you just- make up your goddam--
WHERE AM I OKAY?? FIRST OFF- WHERE?
AND SECOND OF ALL- WHA-
(blows a raspberry)
ya ding dong-
NOOOOOOOOOOO
WHY WOULD YOU DO THAT???
YOU SON OF A BITCH
why would you do that???
I guess no one expected them to die there because why would they have??
Not my fault, Not my fault! That was a hundred percent not my fault!
I dont know what you guys are talking about I am good at games
And I know exactly what I'm doing when I'm playin them!
Okay so stop being a big dumb dumb doof and I'm gunna jump onto these actually correctly this time
N-NO!
THERE WE GO OKAY grabbed on!
I dont know if this' what I was suppose to do but im gunna do it anyways
because it feels right!
I'm following a body Ba-OOoohhhh
you fell down...
Why you fall down?
OH I could have grabbed on here!!!
I COULD HAVE GRABBED ON OVER HERE HAHa!
[laugh transitions to groan of realisation]
Oh, Hi... oh hi
oh hi
Hi OH HI OOhhh Hi Aohh-Hi!
Ho
Ah
Good- This is where all the Quote Unquote "Meat" goes
But you know- One thing I will say!
these- Th-these bags they look distinctly-
Oh no dont fall on me
these bags look distinctly not childlike- So I'm wondering what is-the point of all this?
No- No no
Why did why is this why does this kid get so hungry
Why did you get so hangry so often?
Don't-
Noooo
It's
It's it's not good
Why, why so often?
Oh uh
Oh no
No
Noooo
Noouuuuuhhhh
Oh no
Ohhhh Noooo
Oh no-
Awwwwwhhh nooouuhh..
Aaaaaw nnnnoo..
Aaaaawh noo...
[sob] Ohh noo...
Oh no...
Ah!
Ugh!
Ok, I don't know if there was another option for that I guess
Oh I just drank its' blood
That's all I needed
ok, I guess I'm fine then
alright
Weellll
That was an event
I guess I'm fine for now then
G-t-that's a thing I don't know how much time has passed, so-
Haha-
I guess- I guess I can't exactly say that
this kid is getting super hungry super fast because honestly
how would I know that? I don't know that
Bwssh
Haha~ I know how physics works so I don't
I am not thwarted by your puzzles here, game
I think I have an inkling to my gamer instinct
To know exactly what to do when I need to do it
What's that sound?
Hello?
Ok
Ahh
Can you jump?
Ok
Uh
Ah. I could have waited!
Until I got here! When there's oodles and cabootles of food!
It is nothing but food!
Why did I-
Why did I settle-?
That's the question here
Uhhh
Ugh
(panicky sounds)
What was that?
(sounds of disgust)
What- No
I'm hiding. No! OH GOD!
I THOUGHT I WAS HIDING BEHIND THAT CORNER! I CAN'T SEEEEE
Oh god oh god oh god oh god...
Right in the pot, aye?
Ah, thank you for that
I can't see when-
doorway is blocking me!
What do you want from me? I was trying to go here, I saw this the first time
(sounds of disgust)
Ugh.. Ok. Alright then.
Yeah.. Keep slicing bu- Ugghhhh
What's with your face??!
What is wrong with you??
Wait, what?
Wait
Wait, he's wearing a mask
Wait I'm not-
That's not just his bulbous fat
Maybe it's his bulbous fat. Maybe I'm wrong about that. It-
seemed to me like he might have just been-
I dunno. Seemed like he might have just been wearing a mask on the back of that
but I am not 100% sure
Oh, hi. Yeah! I am hiding! Don't worry about me!
It looks like a mask!
Oh what? Noo... It can't be. No no. That's just the way the graphics are
This is so bizarre
What are you doing over there?!
Alright, here I go, I guess
Don't mind me
OH
Skedaddle with you I guess
No
Didn't mean to do that
Did not mean to do that
Which way are you gonna go?
That's right
That's what I thought
Yeah, there's nothing over there
Yeah- You're-you're real dumb, you know that
Yeah, that's what I thought
Ohh.. Super stupid
Ugh god
The worst kitchen I've ever seen
[singing a happy, gibberish song]
Oopsie poopsie I'm screwed
What you doing there, buddy?
Having trouble breathing?
Yeah, get some spices, you go f- oh
What are you doing?
You didn't hear nothing
You didn't hear nothing!
Uh Oh , Uh Oh
Gonna keep off here
you cant see
NUTHINGGGGG
Go in now and gOOoo die
[odd sounds]
Where am I Where am not going
Why am I not going
Where am I and why am I not going?
I CAN'T SEE MYSELF
I'M AT A GODDAM-
Well I guess I'm gunna stay here for a little bit longer because apperently I can't fricking mOVE?
yeesh.
okay
bout now?
How bout now can we go now-
there we go
finally
Geeze, this game, this game, huh?
(singing a nonsense song)
I'm gonna climb up there, 'den get the fudge outta here
(a little more singing) -no, you- you can't see me, can you?
(a chorus of no's)
Oh. Uh oh. I meant- to grab that!
Oh god [x3], oh oh, you can't do that!
You don't know where I am, do you?
(laughing) He knows exactly where I am, actually.
(imitating the odd gasping sounds the enemy is making)
-guys' got a fricking fish-mouth.
Eh- so gross...
What is wrong with him? Oh geeze-
Y'alright, buddy?
Eh!
(in an odd, blubbery voice) Oh! What was that? Oh!
(back to normal) Man, how did you hand these up here?
These seem like they were, uh,
- they were a  long-arm job if you know 'me-
How did these even get up here?
Who gets these supplies?
How are these fish not rotting? Horribly?
Ugh, weird... frickin' weird...
Alright, I guess we're just gonna climb a wall of fish
Y'know, I- I ate a live rat
And if I had waited, just one more second, I would've been utterly fine.
I would'a been hunky and dor- ugh!
Why do I always end up in toilets?
Why do I- Always end up in toilets?
(mumbling)
Ok, hello-
Ah- I'm in a lovely r- what was that?
Hello?
Are you gonna lead me to a secret, or is this gonna be, y'know- somethin'.
Hello? Tippy-tappy-tippy-toe-y
(mumbling nonsense song)
Oh... sleeping on the job, are we?
Oh, I see a shadow of a key, do I?
Oh!
I see you! I see you!
Ah-- I see /you/.
(mumbling) OH-
No, no, no, It's not time for wakey-wakey eggs and bake-y, it is not time for that at all!
Uh oh! You didn't see nothin'!
Thumpity-thump thump thump...
Uh- What is with that picture?!
Oh, are they brothers? Eh... I don't like the new brother.
New brother's bad brother.
Alright, here we go.
I think i need to do- this!
Ah- grab that.
And then I'm gonna gently set it over there- heh heh.
Cause I'm so smart- gently set that there
And then I'm gonna swing-swong.
This is the one time this is gonna work, right? Ugh!
Grab it! Fuck you.
Fuck you!
You son of a b- I know that's what I was s'posed to do.
Oh, I can just climb up here, okay, that's good!
(grunts of effort)
Okay. Well, I got a key now.
So that's handy.
(singing) I got a key and I'm goin' over here now (nonsense singing) I got a key!
Oh, this is open!
Oh, please tell me that guy's not taking a massive dump.
C'mon wake up little...
Boy Girl I have no idea?
No run
I said efficient not stupid!
whooo slid into the winners circle!
Alright, here we go, here we go, here we go!
Boink!
and boink!
and grab it
and... RUUUUUUUUN!!!
RUUUUUN!!!
ok, where was I running to again?
I've completely forgotten
was it down here?
Broaaar!
Broaaaar!
Broaaaaar!
Alright go go go! Now would be the time to gooooo!
Now would be the time to goooo!
Do you think they're brothers in competing restaurants? Or something like that?
Something stupid
or awesome?
haaa dada
don't know where I'm going
Ha booskie!
ahaha you'll never find me!
Huh how'd this door mysteriously get urpened???
ooh I don't know?
*weird noises* I can't see anything from my mask
Alrighty then
Yeah yeah
ooo yeah
I'm over there
*huffs* Idiot
dummy
is he gonna come back?
*Preparation*
I guess he was just done cooking or something?
yeah okay you just take a breather buddy boo!
boink!
scoop!
yeah tha- that sounded
wh- wh- why am I gonna jump into the trash shoot?
Why-Why did I jump-? *disappointed in self*
Is there gonna be another SHARLACK down here, huh?
Ooh! Plunger! (a rare treasure)
You can use that! *no shit, Sherlock! Ha, puns...*
Well nevermind then I'll just carry on in the...
Garbizh
That I love being in here for a whi-
Oh, I'm here, okay. (nodding of approval)
(Eugh)
Oh...
Oh! It's the same place he just was!
I just happened to go in the...
*Moment of suspense*
Garbizh!
Just to, you know, have some fun.
You have amazing grip strength
to not even have to
to bend your hands in order to hold that
- Welp, there it goes, nevermind
I was just complimenting you and then you proved yourself to be an incompetent goof
Oh your face
I swear, I swear, they're aliens. It's the only explanation to all of this
They're aliens, that is 100% certain.
So, there's gotta be a way, now that that's activated, to climb up and, uh, get on to those hooks, right?
Not that way, though.
its gotta be some other way
can you go around that handle that would be great
Is this soapy and slidy?
k here we go. hello?
oh
there's got to uh oh
eee!
didily didily didily didily ding donggg
yeah what did you -what did you hear? nothing
uh weird how much nothing you heard
but either way the hooks must be going up above
so that must mean. whatcha see? nothing oh nothing ya doof *screams like the brother*
alright good job your an incompetent buffoon
so there's got to be like
OH! the plates of course I can climb the plates
hopefully I don't knock them over
but there's got to be okay but there's got to be one path of plates that is going to lead me right up to it
and I feel like it might be that one right in the center there because there's kinda a spotlight on it
that guy don't seem to be vacating his post so
let me just see if there's another one around here....
no I have a funny feeling its going to be that center stack of plates
right- oooooo he moved. Ha jokes on him he shouldn't have moved
my opportunity to shine ooooo that's not good
can you- ah, jeez you're such an asshole
But maybe I can distract them
uh oh
op, here we go! you guys are dumb, and I'm smart!
what do you see? A whole lotta NOTHING!
OHHH GET WRECKED! GET WRECKED BROS! Oh, yah stupid!
Stupid oh!
*dying dog noises*
why are they so freaked out by this
you'd think it wouldn't be that much of a problem, they're killing too many of these guys as it is
HA HA! I'm A winner
you're a loser
oh-oh my god oh my god. how'd you get over there?
No, no
NO!
ooo, nope. NO! woah, okay, alright, missed me! I think
oh boy, oh boy
Ooh!
missed me!
Woah, uh oh.
EYE!
oh god, they got me good
I didn't know that that was gunna happen that way
*Alieniplier*
*Batman voice* I'm on the dinner plate today
alright lets try this again, hoppidy hoopidy!
OIYeeyeyeye...
no no no no no no NO!
Goddammit! How could I go any faster he knocked a brick in my path!
It ruined all my momentum!
Doobily doo doo boo...
SLITHY SLIDE!
Slid slididy sloo
Ima sneaky peaky
Look at me go
SHEEBIDY DOO!!
OHHH ALMOST GOT ME! but you didn't because you suck
[more singing]
[singing continues] you suck a lot!
[singing continues] IM THE WINNER! WINNER WINNER baby!
anddd here I go
do you like my song?
they don't that's for sure
Ah Shimmey sham!
Okay fine then I guess this is my style--
[MARK AGONY NOISES]
[Squeakiplier] Why would you-
WHY WOULD YOU DO THAT TO MEEE?
It's cus I stopped singing my song isn't it?
It's cus I stopped singing isn't it?
OOOOO I'm soapy!
Ahh this time I'm a REAL slippery bandit!! [how funny]
They ain't never gonna get me this time
okay this time I-
How many times have I fallen off a linear path like that?
that seems like a particularly sticky one!
shouldn't have soaped up before I went through there!
OHHH AND that's an achievement for the kitchen
So we are bLAZIN a trial here
and unfortunately that is all the-
[Confuse mark noises]
That is all the time that I have for this episode
so thank you everybody so much for watching hope you're enjoying it thus far